en las últimas horas se ha conocido que
más y más personas que habitan la
población de bakú están buscando evacuar
la ciudad hasta la semana pasada las
autoridades de esta ciudad hablaban que
al menos cinco mil personas habían
decidido quedarse ellas vivían en
refugios subterráneos vivían sin
electricidad sin agua y de la ayuda
humanitaria que llegaba hasta allí
muchos se reunían durante el día en esos
puntos de invencibilidad donde les daban
comida les daban las medicinas que
necesitaban y también podían cargar sus
móviles es una ciudad que estaba
prácticamente incomunicada sin embargo
después del viernes cuando ya los
enfrentamientos se hicieron mayores y
los ucranianos decidieron destruir
algunos dos de los puentes que estaban
estratégicos en la ciudad especialmente
aquel que de la vía que conduce a
chasear que era la única vía realmente
que daba acceso hacia un lugar seguro
mucha otra población decidió partir y se
conoce que los militares están
intentando ayudar a estas personas a
cruzar a través de un puente militar que
han creado en las últimas horas ellos
caminan hasta allí y ya allí cogen un
transporte que los lleva hasta un lugar
seguro pero también se ha conocido que
en el día de ayer una persona que
intentaba oír murió y dos quedaron
heridos y también algunas agencias que
han llegado hasta allí hablan de cómo
estas poblaciones aledañas o estas zonas
aledañas a este puente son atacadas
permanentemente según el ejército y
analistas militares dicen que la
situación en el frente continúa en el
Igual que ayer en mayor enfrentamientos
callejeros los rusos están atacando
hombre a hombre a las tropas ucranianas
que según una de esas organizaciones que
analiza la guerra dicen que estarían
planeando todo para retirarse hasta
ciertos sectores de batmut pero no para
abandonar la totalidad de la ciudad y
también se ha conocido que esas
poblaciones aledañas a bacmut que
todavía están en control de Ucrania y
que los rusos buscan controlar Para
encerrar la ciudad hay ataques allí ayer
hubo ataques en cada una de ellas pero
siguen en poder de Ucrania según ha
dicho el ejército de este país